Five qualities men look for in a woman
What makes a woman high value marriage material
no, it's not look
so don't think about that
number one: you're faithful
you put him first
and he never doubts your love for him
because you show him each day how much you love him
number two if you show him appreciation
this will make him feel like you're worth working hard for
and a little appreciation goes a long way
No. 3 if you're loving and nurturing
if you take care of your man and you're nurturing him
then he'll see you as a potential good mother to his kids
No. 4 if you have a good attitude
men love emotionally regulated women who are generally happy
this makes men want to be around you
No. 5 take care of yourself
I said this wasn't about looks and it isn't
but you still need to take care of yourself
the way you look doesn't really matter to men
for the most part
But men value feminine woman who smell nice
It doesn't necessarily matter what shape or size you are
basically if you're faithful,
you appreciate him,
you have a good attitude,
you love and nurture him,
and you take care of yourself,
simple qualities that you can have to be a high value woman
this is what men look for
they don't need you to be the most prim and proper
They just need to know that they can trust you
and know that you won't cheat on them
this should go without saying
but high value woman do not cheat on their man
so reflect on all of these
if you wanna be a high value woman to your future partner